it's very uh good to have your voice in
this big conversation when you saw the
pictures
of trump supporters storming the capital
on
this historic january 6 2021 uh were you
surprised
no unfortunately i wasn't surprised
we've seen this
the previews of this we're building and
building and building we understood
that that this was going to be uh
an extra legal and extra political
uh avenue that they would pursue to try
to retain political power
and so i was not shocked and i also
wasn't shocked on a more fundamental
level
which is conservatism and republicanism
traditionally were great respecters
of institutions of american history
but with trump they always live in the
year zero this is always the immediate
moment
and so their anger was taken out not
only on
the the capitol police with fatal
consequences
but also taken out on on the history of
this country
and of our pluralistic society in our
democratic system
they were angry that that their
candidate lost a vote and they didn't do
what americans have done for hundreds of
years
which is to accept those results they
decided instead to have a little
mini rebellion an insurgency if you will
so talk a little bit about uh trump's
role
uh uh of this very day i mean i'm sure
you listen to the speech
he delivered uh around 11 30 or so local
time
would you agree that this was kind of uh
the initiative of this
uh march towards the capital or which
role
does this speak really uh play in this
whole development of this day
well i think the two statements he's
issued since the attack
uh that one minute video in this speech
both of those were only because he feels
he's in legal peril
now he feels he's in is it as a sin
as a degree of political and legal risk
that he did not have before
and i think because of that he is
um trying to hedge his bets now his
followers
are not in any way deterred by this
they are angry um they are they are
energized
they are still talking about doing a
massive march
on the 17th of january and a million
militia march in dc
and armed march in dc on the 20th of
january
i think both of those present remarkable
risks to the stability of the country
uh and the president could and should
say something about it but he will not
let's talk a little bit about the
republican party i mean we saw the
reactions of
mike pence and mitch mcconnell with the
who
finally both accepted the outcome uh
uh of the election but tell us a little
bit what what do you make of their
latest remarks
uh look i think it's a day late and a
dollar short
this this election is the outcome has
been clear since uh since a couple days
after the election
they have all participated in this
ongoing
um sustaining operation to to convince
people that there
was some sort of fraud or cheating or
irregularities of some a certain scam
it was of course all false from the
beginning and yet they persisted in
telling those lies until
today they are they are
in part responsible for
the um the outcomes because they kept
telling people
sure the president's right it's false it
was stolen the election was rigged
you know you've been screwed so josh
hawley and marco rubio and ted cruz
and ron johnson and marsha blackburn and
mitch mcconnell
and all the rest in the senate they took
on
a they took on a
responsibility for what happened
yesterday when they kept
persisting in this lie so i i
i they get no credit they get no credit
for
um for for a last-minute road to
damascus conversions
so how can you give me one second my
dogs are everywhere come on
gross what kind of dogs do you have rick
three german short haired pointers okay
nice ones
so dogs how can the gop get out of this
situation what should they do
now well i'm at the point personally
where i don't really care
what they do they made their bed and
they're gonna have to lay in it for a
while
um they need in my view to have a purge
of trumpism from the party i don't think
they'll do it
i don't think that they're mentally or
politically capable of doing it
and i think it has enormous downside
risks for them but
that does not seem to matter uh
at all that it does not seem to matter
um that that sustaining the lies of
trump and trumpism
has damaged the country they don't care
about that they're a little worried in
the short term about their political
positioning but in the long term they're
not worried about anything
what does that mean for let's say the
more
moderate republicans where where do they
find their political home in the future
well that's a real challenge because
there is no moderate republican party
there's only the trump party or the not
trump party
um you know you have many people who are
very conservative
uh liz cheney in the house you know
plenty of liberals disagree with liz
cheney on a million policy issues but
she has been opposed to the president's
behavior in this thing because she
thinks it's anti-american
anti-small d democratic and
in so far as you have conservatives who
are who are upset with the president
they have nowhere to go
um there that we may be at a point of a
schism
in the party the whig party in america
collapsed in 1854
because the kansas nebraska act that the
whig party endorsed extended slavery
into the west
they could not politically survive that
and the whig party disappeared and died
we may be at a point where the
republican party as we knew it will
disappear and die
be replaced by a trump party and a
center-right party
and you know to make the german analogy
the trump party is the afd
rising insurgent crazy
um and the old republican party is
probably more csu than cdu
but explicitly conservative
so we'll see where that goes in the
coming
in the coming years but there's the
schism is profound
what do we have to expect like let's say
for in
within the next six months or so within
the republican party
what will happen
um we're going to see a massive
massive surge of candidates
who in the 2022 election who are more
like trump
who are more conspiratorial who are more
q anon
who are more crazy who are more off the
rails
those people will be more and more a
centerpiece of
what is going on with the republican
party
it will take a long time before there's
either very purge of those people
or their electoral failures accrue to
the point where other people who are
conservative say
we can't go down that path any longer do
you see any leaders for a more
kind of let's say moderate republican
party are there any figures who would be
willing maybe
to fund their own party or to start
their own party
party building is hard is a hard job in
this world it's a very very tough
job um and i don't think we're going to
end up seeing
a a alternative the republican party in
the 19 in the 2022 cycle
but we may see it in the 24 cycle uh and
i think you you've seen people standing
up
in recent days you know mitt romney ben
sasse
toomey um you know and and those of us
who left the republican party
um you know have all been very vocal so
we may there may be another party in
this country another center right party
in the future i don't know what that's
going to be yet though what does that
all mean for the
com for president-elect joe biden how
can he work
with this uh uh republican party which
we see right now
it's going to be very difficult it's
going to be very hard because they're
going to be dedicated to destroying his
administration from the day one
and joe biden has pressures on the left
and the right
but what he needs to focus on is very
simple
it's one word and it's coveted he needs
to handle the covet crisis
in this country get a vaccination
program in place get the economic relief
moving
because covet is the number one
driving factor once trump is gone
that will be the problem that faces us
in in every moment of the day we're
losing 5 000 americans
uh a day right now this is
this is it's it's horrifying so biden's
number one job is
is dealing with cobin and if republicans
don't want to be along for that ride i
think that's going to be politically
damaging for them
and i think they're going to have
problems down the line because of it
rick um last question should donald
trump be impeached one more time
absolutely
today right now if i were speaker of the
house we would be in session
right now impeaching the president this
very moment
why because he is he is incited
uh insurrection he has committed
sedition
he has attempted to overthrow a legally
constituted u.s election
he has provoked violence he has provoked
an attempted
an attempted takeover of our legislative
body with with consequences that led to
the deaths of five americans
he is responsible for this he is the
proximate cause of this
he should be impeached and removed from
office and he should never be allowed to
to to to hold elected office again
are there any chances chances that this
is going to happen
it's a low probability event but it's uh
certainly moving forward right now with
a great degree of velocity
do you fear violence again in washington
dc absolutely
talk a little bit about it what do you
see coming in the next like
next 10 12 13 days i'm more afraid
i'm more afraid of 25 guys who know what
they're doing
than 2 500 morons charging in and and
smearing poop on the walls
what we sho what this showed was that
the capital could be penetrated it had
no security to speak of
and if those folks had been
isis or al qaeda it could have been
it could have been a mass casualty event
it could have been an event of
of horrifying proportions you know the
irony of the president's
position is that in 1990 excuse me
in 2016 um they called it the flight 93
election named after the flight that the
the passengers brought down in
pennsylvania
uh when that the al-qaeda folks had
hijacked it
that flight was headed for the u.s
capitol and so
a lot of people said well trump's
election is the flight 93 election we
either take out hillary
or we don't know we may die in the
process but we don't know
ironically now they've adopted the
tactics of al qaeda
they've adopted the tactics of terror
they've adopted the tactics
of an insurgency and so if unless we
push back on this very quickly
and with great consequences for the
people involved uh we will get more of
the same i'm afraid
when you saw these pictures what did you
make of the
of the of the police and how could it be
that it was so
easy for these people to storm
there has been a leadership failure in
the capital police of
a tragic and epic proportion i think
there's going to be a lot of
investigations going forward on this
to find out what and how it happened
what what happened and how
and i think it is i think it is
incredibly dangerous
that they were opening the gates for
these folks they were letting them in
and once they were let in all bets were
off
what are we going to see on january 20th
we want we won't see donald trump he's
not going to attend the inauguration
and i'm okay with that i am hopeful we
will see a peaceful transfer of power
i am hopeful that that the president
will see
uh his legal peril if he continues to
encourage violent
insurgency and sedition um and i am
hopeful that we're going to see joe
biden sworn in on
at 1201.
you